[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing why elves
are well
house elves despite possessing pretty
powerful magical abilities as you may
recall elves and the concept of house
elves are introduced in the chamber of
secrets when harry meets dobby the
resident house elf of draco malfoy's
family and the family's home malfoy
manor
through this introduction we discover
that the upper class of the wizarding
world all seem to own house elves elves
who are magically bound to serve their
masters and work in servitude for
well-to-do visiting families without
compensation their tasks range from
cleaning to cooking and running errands
all without question
the only way that they can be freed from
their magical enslavement is if their
master gives them a piece of clothing of
course this sounds quite miserable and
so
it was unsurprising when we learned that
dobby longs to be free from his
indentured servitude to the cruel malfoy
family who mistreat him and
underestimate his abilities and
intelligence this of course inevitably
leads to harry helping dobby secure his
freedom
tricking lucius malfoy into tossing an
old sock to the elf however despite
dobby being the first house elf we are
introduced to we come to learn that he
is actually quite an anomaly when
compared to the majority of the elves
that we come across throughout the
remainder of this series from dobby's
friend to winky who harry meets at the
quidditch world cup when he mistakes her
for dobby and to creature the miserable
house elf of the black family who is
inevitably left to harry after sirius
black's death through these and other
elves that we are introduced to
throughout harry potter we are led to
believe that most house elves actually
enjoy their enslavement in fact winky
after being released from service with
her family goes into a severe depression
what's more each and every elf
physically punishes themselves if they
betray their master in any way
in the goblet of fire at least the novel
version we are also introduced to many
elves all of whom are employed by
hogwarts
while it's true some of these elves are
eventually paid for the work they
perform at the school
many of them were unwilling to accept
payment for their services
many also take great offense when
hermione attempts to free them from
their positions through her organization
spew
that is the society for the promotion of
elfish welfare now i suppose you could
argue that the self-punishment and
rejection of compensation is part of the
magic that ensures a house elf obeys
every command of their master and asks
for nothing in return for example
creature who has an extreme dislike of
muggle-born witches and wizards punishes
himself after insulting harry and his
friends due to the fact that harry is
his master however we also see dobby
punish himself for talking ill of the
malfoys after he's been freed from
servitude to that family which indicates
that it may be a strong biological trait
of extreme loyalty rather than that of
magic which forces them to behave this
way
speaking of magic you may be wondering
what is it about elven magic
specifically that makes house elves as
formidable as i'm suggesting
well first of all elven magic is quite
different from wizard magic to perform
it elves require no ones and no
incantations they seem to simply have
the ability to cast their magic at will
and it's often more advanced than that
of wizard kind which is something that
harry himself notes at one point
for example they are able to use their
magic in places that witches and wizards
are unable to
they can operate from place to place
including into areas that are heavily
fortified by magic to prevent such a
thing
house elves are also skilled fighters
which is proven by the role they play in
the battle of hogwarts throughout the
series we also see house elves use
several spells that witches and wizards
are incapable of breaking
on the whole elven magic and elves
ability to perform that magic seems
quite superior to most of the power
wielded by humans within the wizarding
world
in fact perhaps prior to elves being
enslaved as house elves wizard kind was
rather threatened by the species magical
abilities
this does provide a rather strong
motivator to attempt to suppress and
harness elfish power for their own gain
anyway while all of this gives us a good
insight into how the disposition of
elves seems ideal for servitude and why
witches and wizards may have enslaved
the species in the first place it does
not explain how was it kind managed to
become and remain the masters of this
powerful species
well as it happens i have a few theories
the first theory i've heard from fans is
one i'm not too keen on myself
some people have suggested that elves
are a creation of wizard kind made with
magic for the express purpose of serving
magical high society i'm pretty quick to
disregard this theory for a few simple
reasons number one elves are common
throughout all kinds of magical lore
if jk rowling was going to create a
magical wizard made creature for the
wizarding world i don't believe she
would have chosen the species so well
known throughout other works of fantasy
and fiction the second and final reason
is that if elves were created by wizards
i don't believe they would have created
a species with such personality why
chance it that an elf like dobby would
seek freedom or one like creature would
be so miserable the next theory however
i think is a rather strong one
this one takes into account genetic
traits evolution and natural selection
although in this case i don't quite
believe the selection to be so natural
imagine that wizards being the larger
and presumably stronger of the two
species sheltered elves centuries ago
from other more menacing magical
creatures at first this could have been
more of an informal arrangement in which
wizards offered protection to elves and
in return elves helped out around the
house
perhaps it started innocently enough
with preparing a meal or two or making
the beds at the beginning of the day
but then over time it's possible that
the elves who provided witches and
wizards with better service were treated
better the more independent-minded elves
may have been cast out and possibly
killed off without the protection of
wizards or simply left without much
opportunity
in the way of finding a mate
after all like many other species it's
not impossible to imagine that an elf
with a job was more desirable to a
potential spouse than one with no
prospects from there it's possible that
wizards further manipulated the
evolution of elves by breeding the most
obedient and docile of the species with
each other after all wizarding
households only seem to have one elf at
a time which leads to the question of
procreation
how is this species continuing to
reproduce that is unless their masters
are organizing opportunities for
subsequent lines of households to be
created
this is quite a sinister thought and for
the sake of house elves i would hope
it's untrue however i just can't think
of how else house elves have continued
their bloodlines
this theory would also explain why
despite their powerful magic house elves
remained enslaved
because they've been bred to enjoy their
servitude
that said one flaw i find in this theory
is that for a household like dobby who
did not enjoy being enslaved why wasn't
he able to break out of bondage he did
not like serving the malfoys and he is
powerful
so why wasn't he able to break free
using his own magic i suppose it could
be argued that overthrowing his masters
for freedom would be against his genetic
makeup
just as it was in his very nature to
bang his head against the wall after
insulting the malfoys despite no longer
serving them for now i guess that
explanation will have to suffice
one final theory i'd like to touch on
before we end today's video is based on
the fact that i don't believe we are
given the whole story when it comes to
elves in the wizarding world
perhaps in addition to the house elves
who enjoy serving wizard kind there are
also free elves thriving in the wild
after all they are an incredibly
powerful species so it's possible that
they could simply be living free
unaffected by both magical and muggle
society which brings us back to the idea
that if witches and wizards offered
protection to elves hundreds of years
ago perhaps it was only the most docile
and timid of elvenkind who approached
wizards in search of a safer existence
and while this group of elves evolved
within the confines of their servitude
wild elves evolved entirely differently
perhaps elves in the wild are unruly and
disloyal with their natural selection
evolving in accordance with the traits
that would have best kept them alive
should they come up against other
menacing magical creatures and with that
we've come to the end of another video
what did you think
do you agree with my theories let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
and as always if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to like it and subscribe to
the channel
until next time
dobby is a free elf
[Music]
you